you me and my little emmy right here
i know i know i know it's the emmy
nominations baby
almost a year old now
um can i hold her not that kind of baby
let's get back to business the nominees
let's get to it when i first met her i
was just
immediately in love it's zendaya's world
we're just living in vendea euphoria yes
the actress made history today landing
her second emmy nod for euphoria
becoming the youngest two-time leading
acting nominee in addition zendaya
scored two extra nominations for her
musical collab on songs elliott song and
i'm tired and no we aren't done yet
zendaya's co-star sydney sweeney are
joining the emmy list too
as well as the entire show being
nominated for outstanding drama series
hey kenny would you like to be in my
group today
uh
not really
it's the spirit and the history
continues with quinta brunson who
becomes the first black woman to receive
three comedy emmy nominations for her
show abbott elementary napping
outstanding comedy series lead actress
and writing and her reaction
overjoyed telling e.t canada in part
quote creating this show has been the
greatest gift and to have it recognized
in this way is the dream this is what i
meant to do squid game
[Music]
squid game becomes the first non-english
show to secure a nod in the main drama
category while star li jung-jae nabs
lead actor in a drama telling e.t canada
quote it is a tremendous honor to be
nominated together with these brilliant
actors we have two options i slap you
across the face or we just skip to the
part where you say thanks kid that was
tough to hear uh not the slapping one
officially renewed for a third season
yesterday only mergers in the building
picks up 17 emmy nods with both steve
martin and martin short grabbing lead
actor and nominated for outstanding
comedy series selena gomez becomes the
second latina to be nominated as a
producer the first salma hayek do you
love barry burkman no i don't this is
our turn to make history and i believe
we're going to do just that
popular contenders barry and ted lasso
both grabbed a nom for outstanding
comedy and today we chat with actor
henry winkler about his show's
nomination i've gotten a lot of
nominations and um i have not
actually
walked up on the stage the sense of
what's to come
is very exciting it truly is uh it does
not get them yellowjackets received
seven emmy nods today and serious star
christina ricci tells us how she found
out hint she was sleeping well my baby
was teething really badly all last night
so i overslept and my husband tried to
wake me up and then woke up later to
like crazy amounts of texts and calls
also soaking up her nomination kaylie
cuoco who posted this insta video of her
reaction with her boyfriend tom who was
also an emmy nominee